[Music]
welcome back to Hannity everyone I'm
Tammy Bruce now the new extreme
Democratic Party continues to drift
further and further left embracing open
borders higher taxes and of course far
left socialism none of that does any
good for Humanity as we've seen
historically and get this even
Democratic insiders are now admitting
that Bernie Sanders has a path to the
nomination from Politico quote suddenly
Bernie Sanders presidential campaign is
being taken seriously Democratic
officials political operatives and
pundits are reconsidering Sanders
chances and if that isn't disturbing
enough congresswoman Ocasio cortes said
she'd be quite honored to be his vice
president while admitting she's too
young to even hold the office so tonight
couldn't be more clear the new extreme
Democrats are running the party driving
the narrative and putting so-called
moderates like Joe Biden if you want to
call him a moderate I guess in this
world he appears to be put putting him
on the defensive because while Biden
clings to his frontrunner status the
campaign continues to be plagued by
awkward gaffes a weak record and his son
hunter shady dealings overseas but of
course the media continues playing
defense for him
let's take a look listen I don't think
Trump is playing chess or checkers I
think he's playing Hungry Hungry Hippos
I get why the president wants a circus
right a circus is a circus it's good
friend everyone gets confused we end up
talking about hurt under Biden that's
not good for the Democrats and once we
start going off to hunter Biden what's
next the CrowdStrike guy diamond and
silk you know like it's going to be just
as crazy mm-hmm yeah so that's in the
future tense crazy
so remember Joe Biden is literally on
tape admitting to a quid pro quo with
Ukraine leveraging US taxpayer aid to
get the prosecutor fired that was
investigating Burr yzma holdings and his
zero experience Sun hunter and not only
that but a private investigation from a
private investigation firm is alleging
in a new court filing that hunter Biden
is actually the subject of multiple
criminal investigations but the media
would rather just ignore it and ignore
just how disconnected and how
dangerous and just how destructive this
new democratic party has become joining
me now for a reaction is Trump 2020
campaign secretary Kaley McKinney along
with the Washington Times columnist and
Fox News contributor Charlie hurt and
Washington Examiner senior campaign
reporter Carrie picot Carrie let me
start with you because this entire
environment here when you're looking at
the media covering for the Democrats
that the nature of what it is they're
covering for accusing Donald Trump of
wanting the circus he is not in charge
of the Democratic Party he didn't choose
these candidates that you know what
they're dealing with them the mess of
what Barack Obama left them in the wake
of Obama care and his eight years so
Donald Trump is sitting back trying to
run the country at the same time are
they looking at obviously I think any of
these individuals can become the nominee
but it is going to require the
Democratic machine effectively to then
anoint one clearly they're still nervous
about Biden are they serious about
Bernie Sanders do you think well right
now what we're seeing is Bernie Sanders
go back into the spotlight because
remember Tammy there was a period of
time when Bernie Sanders was number one
right and the Democratic establishment
all of a sudden was kind of freaking out
a bit so they're kind of saying yo Joe
you better jump in at some point and
kind of save us but then Joe Biden
almost sudden he's having his gaffes
having being tangled Mint's with his son
and now you know we begin to see
Elizabeth Warren have her pop you know
Buddha judge have his pop and then all
of a sudden they're going back down
again now we're seeing Bernie Sanders
pop up again and they're beginning to
wonder it's gonna bounce around Charlie
it almost comes around to who the media
is paying attention to right Bernie
Sanders after his heart attack it was
kind of kid gloves there he's not really
taken to task by the media at all
Elizabeth Warren was because of the
absurd Medicare for all fifty two
trillion dollar circus so she took some
hits so is she but the moment that any
attention is paid to them they sink
Charlie do you think
that this is going to be one of those
cases where either there they're hoping
he will but now with Elizabeth Warren
going away and going down and somebody
who does not mention charlie is
Bloomberg where do you see all of this
coming out in the next month or two as
we head into the caucuses well I gotta
tell you Tammy you know all along I have
have believed that somebody like Joe
Biden although he is completely marched
away from his quote/unquote centrist
appearing legacy of Obama sort of
platforms that that you know I do think
that he most likely represents the the
broad cross-section of the Democratic
Party but of course as you point out
he's been running a disastrous campaign
it would not surprise me one bit to see
out of all of this wreckage to see a
Bernie Sanders wind up with the
nomination after all he won the
nomination in 2016 it just so happens
that the DNC and the Hillary Clinton
campaign got together and conspired to
take it away from him but it wouldn't
surprise me but I also think that if
Bernie Sanders winds up as the nominee
for the party I think he clearly loses
not only because he's just commit all
he's crazy and all of his his policies
are totally unpalatable to general
election voters I think they're even
unpalatable probably to the a broad
cross-section of Democratic you know
when I was on the left when they
arguments what was is that even bringing
up the subject moves and it being
accepted as a legitimate thing to
discuss moves it forward that it's like
you have five steps forward three steps
back so we can't dismiss that this is an
effort perhaps to change the mentality
of Americans on the scene we've seen
though what they didn't anticipate was
Donald Trump reminding them of the
greatness of the American ideal and the
importance of the Republic and and
certainly capitalism Kaleigh at the same
time you've got the other thing and I
you know I've always a little bit seen
the hunter Biden dynamic is a bit of a
district of a distraction but it really
in a way sits at the core of what the
problem is with the with the swamp in
that it's this nepotism money and you
wonder it's like how do you become a
multi-millionaire
in public
and now this is the scene that seems to
explain that to us really stripped bare
do you think that this is obviously
hunter Biden's problem seemed to
increase by the day is this something
that will affect Joe Biden if in fact he
continues to stay at the top of the heap
it certainly will because look Tammy
when I travel the nation go to all the
president's rallies one thing I hear
repeatedly is about the Washington swamp
and this notion that politicians go in
there enriched are they profit off of
their time in public service and there's
no better example of that than hunter
Biden who had no experience in oil and
gas but gets this lucrative contract in
Ukraine gets this lucrative deal over in
China both coincidentally after his
father either leads the foreign
relations with the country or visits
there in the case of China this sits at
the center and when Hillary Clinton had
her email problem and the bleach fitting
and all of this came out CNN MSNBC they
did their best to cover it to hide it I
was a contributor at the time I saw it
happen their attempt to hide these
scandals from the American people but I
can tell you this the American people
are smart they see through it and they
will see this scandal for what it is
just like they did with the Hillary you
know Kerry I think one of the things
that's different in all of that we're
discussing here is social media and is
cable television is the fact that in
real time now you can receive the news
on a smartphone that you can get
information as its as it's occurring
that may be the hunter Biden thing if
you if you only had three networks to
rely on that we're covering up you
wouldn't have all the information be
able to make those determinations and
then you've got Alexandria Ocasio Cortez
who seems to be a representation of the
problems there when it comes to voting
and to literacy economically and
historical literacy of who we are and
she's attached herself to Bernie to
Bernie Sanders clearly it's not the
kennedy shriver democratic party anymore
but do see that social media is part of
what is making this change and how the
american people are responding and what
they're willing to put up with because
we're learning more every day
well certainly I mean social media has a
lot to do with this Tammy but remember
Alexandria Ocasio Cortez also provides a
lot of energy to this this a primary for
the Democrats that the Democrats and
cells in this primary really can't
provide but remember she is not old
enough and unfortunately they're gonna
have to wait maybe until 2020 well or if
they if they imagine that this is the
future they've got some bigger problems
than we even could imagine because
Americans are have rejected that in 16
they're rejecting it now and with
everything else we've seen I think
they're going to reject it in 2020 so
it's it's a heartbreak it's an important
legacy of the American Republic but
somebody there is going to have to get
their act together Kailey Carey Charlie
thank you very much for joining me
tonight I appreciate it